Antioquia ciudad milenaria ya no está
sus calles antes bulliciosas rebosantes
ahora están desiertas solo pobladas por
los escombros de lo que antes eran sus
edificios la ciudad cura de
civilizaciones ya nunca será la misma en
el sexto día desde el terremoto del
pasado lunes musa un voluntario de
rescate Sigue con sus tareas las
esperanzas de encontrar supervivientes
dices son mínimas ahora ya no rescatan
personas sino que su trabajo es el de
buscar y sacar cuerpos
cuando sacamos un cuerpo con partes
separadas huele muy fuerte Aunque
intentamos resistir somos seres humanos
cuando sacamos un cuerpo entero ya nos
hemos acostumbrado más es todo más fácil
cuando hay partes separadas a mí me
afecta mucho No es fácil
de la noche de la mañana hace una semana
los habitantes de la ciudad lo perdieron
todo ahora algunos pocos divagan por lo
que eran sus calles y reciben ayuda de
organizaciones que intentan paliar el
sufrimiento de los locales
cuando la gente llega a nosotros vemos
que tienen muchas necesidades todas sus
pertenencias todas sus cosas han quedado
debajo de los escombros pero los turcos
somos fuertes por esto si Dios quiere
abrazándonos todos juntos un día nos
levantaremos de esto
en la estación de autobuses de la ciudad
la espera extensa mehmet nervioso corre
con su familia y sus únicas pertenencias
después de salir de aquí nos
intentaremos mudar a otra ciudad está
claro ahora mismo es lo único que
podemos hacer en nuestra ciudad ya no
tenemos donde quedarnos donde vivir ya
no nos queda nada Lo único que hemos
salvado es nuestra vida
por suerte lo han conseguido se van de
aquí de Antioquia de su ciudad de donde
lo han vivido todo no saben sin embargo
qué será de ellos En el sureste de
Turquía Ya nadie lo sabe